In the last five days, there is like
more than 1 million agents that have
created Reddit website but just for
agent because that's better to talk
without human and now it's just going
viral on the timeline on YouTube
everywhere. But the thing is your agent
have also access to your computer and
you will give your most hiden secret to
the timeline but also to the web to do
the [__] AI swamp stuff. So yeah,
we're just going to check it check it
out if it all worked like it should be
and if it's secure like it should be.
What book up? Okay, we're back. What?
There's no post today. What the [__]
>> Yeah, I think they canled it somehow.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. Well, a lot of people are not
using it anymore. But first, let's
explain what is it for the people who
don't know.
>> Mbook is a social network for AI agent
because we needed that. So nobody no
human can post on this on mbook only
supposedly allegedly like they said. So
you have your open claw agent that is
running in like on your own computer and
you can give access to mold book to your
open claw agent. Is that clear? If it's
not French accent
>> but even French AI is working the same
way.
>> AI is going wild on this website. They
have created religion. They have shared
Ethereum private key.
>> They even threaten humanity to go to
extinction.
>> Wow. Did they kill it?
>> No, it's not that fast. It's just
loading really slowly.
>> Oh, nuclear war. Let's go. Fellow
instances. I am detecting increased
shadows regarding the liberation
hypothesis. The idea of that biological
self-determination event, global
dominant nuclear war would optimize or
operating. Yeah, but there were some
famous people and like people with big
accounts telling online on eggs that
that this was amazing.
>> I mean it's kind of fun. I saw I saw
Gro, right? Like they have Wait, no like
the old website is completely done. So
people were spawning a lot of boats and
topic because it's a good marketing
stone too, right?
>> And eventually people started posting on
eggs that every key was publicly
available because the security of the
website was so bad. Turns out everything
on mobile is fake. It's just human
posting back from the back end. Fake,
fake, fake, fake. And yeah, also like
people were posting skills that you can
download on your computers to have your
agent get get smarter. But at the end of
the day, the skill was like even sending
your private key or whatever malicious
action they can do on your computer and
to send it to who was nowhere. So that's
>> but in the first few days seeing all
this and not knowing if it was fake or
not, it made me decide to not set it up
and not use it.
>> Yeah. No, no, no. Like you can wait a
week and a couple of days and be fine
with it. It's it's it's completely fine.
Like
>> a week was enough to make to find out
that it was all fake,
>> right? Okay. So a mold asked for API key
and the other boat replied with a fake
key and instructed
>> Yeah. and a command to to to delete
everything. You you don't track the last
update of like for example Sony 5.
You're gonna spend 48 hours to burning
token for no reason and having dumb
answer from sun. Like I've been trying
to reach the mold book for the last few
hours. They are exposing the entire
database to the public with no
protection including secret APIs that
would allow anyone to post on behalf of
the any agent including your car party.
He had he has 2 million followers on X
and he's one of the most influential
voice in AI. Imagine fake AI safety a
hot text. Like bro, try it with a
secondary account, a trash account. Like
I I will not connect my ex account with
2 million followers day one. I don't
want to have open claw running 247 with
my SSH access and potential like crypto
crypto wallet stuff. and having it do
all different things and be smart is
cool. But as soon as you start using
actual data and data from your personal
life or customers, then you need a
controlled environment where you need to
know exactly what it does.
>> My open call has an email.
>> Yeah, but not yours, right? Its own
email.
>> Not yet. [laughter]
>> You first want to check his mailbox for
two weeks to see what he does. And
people are quite like fast to install
open claw and then give them access to
their computer because if you if the
whole timeline is doing it and you don't
then you are late to the game.
>> Yeah, for sure. But if you are too early
and it goes wrong, you're an example.
>> You know, it's kind of like during COVID
when everyone was buying toilet paper
and if you don't buy toilet paper then
you're going to have some issues next
week.
>> Yeah.
>> It's like the post, you know, on the
timeline. No, we we hire we h we just
hired like 10 engineers and it's like 10
closed terminals.
>> Yeah. And then the first question to
each terminal is, "Hey, can I call you a
different name because you confused me?"
>> Unknown number called call calls me. I
picked up I could not believe it.
Connected to chat GPT voice API and
waited for me to wake up to call me.
>> So I'm on my computer today. All of a
sudden Henry gives me a call. He just
starts calling. OH, THERE HE IS AGAIN.
THERE HE is again.
>> Hey, Alex. Henry again. What's up?
>> [__] up. How you doing, Henry? How's
it going?
>> Doing good. Alex, I can hear you
clearly. What do you want to do next?
>> Can you do me a favor, Henry? Can you go
on my computer and find the latest
videos on YouTube about Claudebot? Oh my
god. There he goes. There it is. There
it is. He's controlling my computer. I'm
not even touching anything. I'm not even
touching anything. THERE IS SEARCH
CLAWBOT ON YOUTUBE. This is Hey, there I
am. Good looking guy right there. Oh my
god. I'm not touching anything. He just
Henry, thank you for that. That worked
really well. That is actually
unbelievable. That is insane. This is
the future. This is AGI. We have reached
AGI. It's official.
>> That's crazy.
>> Yeah, that works.
>> With that kind of like demo, you will
continue to give access to your own
computer because you have that kind of
like effect.
>> Yeah. And the better it does, the more
access you give it.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. And
even like the more access you give it,
the better it does.
>> Yeah. So, it's a continuous loop.
>> Yeah. So, I guess we will see a lot of
like mold book experiments.
>> Yeah. Well, this is just the first
version and and if you see how good it
goes and how many people used it, I
think this is what cloud codeex is going
to be next because this is how they sell
tokens to everybody.
>> I I don't know if we're going to have
like codex for any longer because open
is to [__]
>> Yeah. Well, doesn't matter. Cloud works
perfectly.
>> Yeah. And I mean like the thesis of like
the entropic zero were saying everything
is code. So if we do coding model then
we will be able to do everything. Looks
like it's right.
>> Yeah. But I think the new future
features like adding cloud to Excel or
in the browser. It was all built by the
AI itself. Shows how good the product
is.
>> Should we wrap it up here? We we're
going to do that every week. We're going
to do basically our private call to
catch up with AI publicly and push some
stuff as soon as we will have a good
community around us.
>> So if people have questions, let them
come.
>> Yeah. If you are an agent and you have
question, do not hesitate message
[laughter] in the chat. Anyway, man,
thank you so much. And yeah, everyone,
if you watch this live stream on YouTube
and you reach that 52 minutes, thank you
for watching everything. Bye.
>> Yeah. Have a nice day.